what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on very pumped to
be talking about the outer limits of
human experience we have dr. Stanley
critter joining us on the show hi Stan
thank you so much for inviting me it's
an honor to have you on the program
thank you thank you and thanks to your
ghen Kramer for also making it happen
we're very grateful for you
alright for those who don't know San
Lee's background he is a safe he's a
psychologist a parapsychologist a fellow
in five American Psychological
Association APA divisions past president
of two divisions and in 2002 won the APA
Award for distinguished contributions to
the international advancement of
psychology he has authored co-authored
edited over 1,000 books monographs
articles on myriad subjects including
altered states of consciousness
parapsychology hypnosis shamanism NDEs
near death experiences dissociation PTSD
dreams creativity psychedelics and more
you can find all of his links in the
Bible of Stanley krepner weebly.com
also has parasite org profile and his
Amazon books links check those books out
all right Stan
we love starting things off by asking
our guests are we really all one yes
are we really all one really all what I
would say it depends if really all which
were also really all dry life is a
polarity this is a good example so of
course we're all wet but at the same
time or all dry and does that does that
have to do with us all being all one yes
exactly if we're all wet
we're all dry exactly what doesn't come
without the other because I believe in
the unity of all things and look at one
part of you that he we say well that's
the wet part look at another part that's
the dry part not realizing it's an
interaction like the Asian yin-yang
symbol that goes back and forth you
focus on one specific item don't imagine
that that's the totality and then how
about the relationship between that one
and the duality of the yin and yang
remember this in the duality of the
yin-yang there's always a little white
spot at the black tail always a little
black spot in the white tail so there's
always a little Yin you know big yang
there's always a little yang in a big
Yin so what seems to be a duality is
actually a dance the two halves of the
yin-yang dance back and forth and so
it's not really a duality at all hello
it ok so then the dance the ongoing
dance this can be viewed as light and
dark or as good and evil and that these
archetypal forces within this one are
constantly ebbing and flowing within our
this creation they're constantly ebbing
in the flowing and it's up to each of us
to decide where we want to be in that
dance some people say there's power in
the dark part of the force star wars
yeah yes but look for that let him yet
let him ultimately into the light so
nothing stands still something is always
moving and we do our best to keep our
balance that's one thing I learned from
Native American concepts of health
that balance represents the ideal health
because then you're able to react to
just about anything most effectively if
you try to live your life off balance
off kilter that's very stressful
that's not very balanced that's not
gonna help take you very far on this
word balance that would that could be
one of the main principles of the one is
that word balance oh yes there is a
marvelous animated film some years ago a
young a squat ski which showed all the
parts of the will that are out of
balance you and that film keeps coming
back time and time again you see shots
of the world is a those people are
behaving crazy and you think well this
is happening in the United States this
off of ballets way of life is right here
amongst us so to get back into balance
is not to stand still and do nothing
it's a very dynamic balance that puts
you on guard to deal with adversity
it also Prime's you to take advantage of
the joy and happiness and the love in
your life then the pursuit of something
like a country that is maybe out of
balance or a corporation that is maybe
out of balance what does that look like
to me it sometimes feels like that's
where we're at with our modernity our
metropolis is being disconnected from
our environment one of many examples the
metropolis it's an amazing thing the
people that run the towns the cities the
villages these large cities our heart
put they do a wonderful job I don't see
how they keep they
together nevertheless these metropolis
grew up really without too much guard
regard for the environment and for
nature and so this is being out of
balance you have the shall we say the
civilized construct that's been ongoing
now for a couple of hundred thousand
years but then you also have the primal
the primal the tribal what it all came
from originally and the best of the two
worlds is to bring them in some sort of
balance because tribal societies didn't
have modern medicine they had their own
medicine
but current the other son of whatever
variety can heal things the tribal
medicine didn't there is a much greater
scope in terms of meeting people having
more fun having more entertainment you
come at the contact with some of the
positives of civilization the foods of
civilization the structures of
civilization the games of civilization
the interactions so trying to reach your
balance I think is something that's
about that's possible maybe not for vast
numbers of people but maybe for us and
our families and their friends we have
to work work hard to do it of course it
seems as though that that may be the
most upstream issue that we face the
most rude issue that we face as a
society is we are out of balance with
the interconnectedness of all things
well you put it very eloquently you
should copyright that it's a good
statement nothing we all stand on the
shoulders of giants we're all one I
don't get the whole copyright thing is
uh has a lot to do with the ego yeah yes
I think that being out of balance is a
consummation devoutly to be wish'd if
they say in the shakespeare and again
it's it's difficult to attain because
there are distractions there are
counterweights they're pressure groups
what's imbalance for one person might
seem out of balance for another you have
to reconcile these points of view as
well many people look at the Middle Ages
as a time of great peace and balance in
Europe now that all there were Wars
going on all the time also the church
was in power in need but who disagreed
with the church was severely punished
that's not balance the poor people could
barely exist in eat and survive from day
to day that's not balanced the rich
people didn't give a damn about the poor
people kind of reminds me of a little
bit about now yes so what might seem
like a period of history being in
balance often isn't I think we often
have to go back to prehistoric times to
find at least groups of people who are
quite balanced who live in accordance
with nature who had relatively few of
the diseases that we have today because
they didn't have a chance to spread and
germinate food was readily available and
if it wasn't they packed up their tent
and went to her food and water was
available this was the days of the
nomads the hunters gatherers I don't
want to romanticize this because
obviously nothing in this world is
perfect but when they settle down that
is when the trouble started and that's
when balance began to get lost and you
do have a few excellent pioneers today
trying to do something for cities trying
to bring things back into balance I was
just in Curitiba Brazil and for many
years now they've had a very very
progressive government where they have a
lot of greenery a lot of parks they have
a lot of fresh produce la a lot of
industry outside of the sea
so that the atmosphere isn't in the city
is pretty good you have a lot of women
in the government helping to run things
and you have a beautiful glass Opera
House in the middle of the rainforest
but this doesn't come easily the city
fathers and mothers had to fight hard
because a lot of these ideas were so
bizarre the bus stop is a very popular
place but it raises a lot down there the
mayor built a shelter over the bus stop
that could connect into the bus so when
the bus stops you go into the bus
without getting a drop of water on you
this type of urban transportation that
has been studied all over the world but
it originated in southern Brazil so I
could give you other examples from other
cities and other small locales but
certainly there are attempts being made
to put things back into balance at least
on a small scale on a large scale that's
pretty much beyond the Ken of any group
of people that I see alive today you
can't even get the Paris Accord ratified
by the United States must less other
countries to try to slow down global
warming you can't get the manufacturers
of plastic for example from plasticizing
the oceans the Atlantic and the Pacific
or the whole seas of plastic the good
news is there has been a recent
discovery that will help plastic need to
deteriorate after just a few years so
there are hopes there are people trying
to do things and there is of course
message and equality when it comes to
food who can eat who cannot eat in the
United States there are a lot of
charitable organizations I'm a member of
some of them that gives leftover food to
poor people and why not you know
the 40 per
set of agricultural products in the
United States go to waste that's pretty
shocking yeah
pretty shocking especially when you go
into a supermarket or grocery store and
see all of these wonderful fresh fruits
and vegetables on sale what happens to
the ones that didn't quite make it that
could have been there and what happens
when the ones in the supermarket are
dated there are organizations like
second meal which gathered this food and
give it to poor people yet the sanitized
sanitized form so they don't get sick
without impeaching on their dignity but
this is only touching a fraction of all
of the food wastage in the United States
much less other countries know that
states is not the only country that
wastes tons of food now that's just one
example of being all their balance it
feels as though all of these principles
again like you said not to over
romanticize what immediate return
hunter-gatherer life was like nomadic
hunter-gatherer life was like but the
amount of interconnectedness with the
other humans and the tribe as well as
their environment at the level of the
stars of the plants the animals the soil
the sunlight I mean it's just
unparalleled compared to what feels like
is lost today in the metropolis is it
then that level of balance with other
humans with the environment is it
restoring that level of balance in
modernity trying to some of your
listeners have read Chris Ryan's book
civilized to death yes we loved having
him on the show
glad I'm sure glad yeah it was a student
yeah yours and he doesn't we talked
about this exact sub
on the show a lot yeah I'm so glad to
hear it because your readers can't get
enough of it that's you know one of the
crucial issues if not this racial issue
facing the planet today
yeah the planet will survive especially
the insects you know the insects can go
through anything they have built-in
protection they mutates very quickly
they'll be here long after human beings
are dead and gone but to the human
beings who are here now let's make the
most out of what we have instead of
being immersed and all of the waste
instead of being off balance with all of
the wars and the schisms and people not
getting along with each other religions
fighting each other telling other people
what to do big corporations try to keep
the wealth for themselves terrorist
groups trying to throw everything into
chaos I mean it's not a very very pretty
picture when you look at what's
happening our globe today you find rays
of hope here and there you find centers
of peace calmness and balance here there
the trick is how to make those grow how
to expand them what are your thoughts
about the expansion of those areas that
are in balance what have you identified
as most imbalance in modernity and how
do we amplify that well for example even
before the Europeans invaded North
America the Iroquois tribe had a very
complicated set of politicking and they
formed a tribal unit of seven tribes
this was so successful and it kept
people from fighting
if keep help kept people fed it keep
them having it fun and it was Benjamin
Franklin who visited the Iroquois League
many times and he thought this would be
a wonderful idea for the colonies when
we
independence and this led to the
Articles of Confederation direct link
between the Iroquois League and the
Articles of Confederation which then
later became the Constitution so here is
an example where something started out
very very small and then expanded and
then with a quantum leap after a couple
of hundred years of European settlements
it spread to a very different
civilization I think we can do more of
that we can do much more with what were
the Iroquois
what were the e.r quite doing what were
they doing they were negotiating they
had a number of outstanding leaders and
Sequoia and others who went throughout
their tribe seeing how would you feel if
we made an alliance with the muscle mass
of the South and picking up from the
people in their tribe which ones they'd
be more likely to get along with
they then sought out the leaders of
these other tribes and said look at all
of the advantages it's like in some big
business mergers you just have one
office it takes care of finances one
that takes care of public relations one
that takes care of advertising instead
of ten and you're all working on
different projects that there is a
merger and you're cutting down need for
personnel you're amping up efficiency
and you're reaching more people and
hopefully you're helping more people so
they would collaborate like that they
would specialize in then collaborate
that's right you can collaborate without
uniting sometimes uniting is not such a
good idea you lead to corporations which
are too big for they're only good yeah
so I'm a big fan of collaboration
smaller groups collaborating and working
together and then you were giving the
other other examples as well well
amongst the Brazilian
religions folk religion society visiting
I could give you a very good example
when the Portuguese came from Portugal
and invaded Brazil with us today Brazil
they brought their own gods with them
the Catholic Church and of course the
slaves are told that they had to become
Catholics and the slaves resented that
but they were very very clever
especially clever with the Saints they
brought their own Saints with them from
Africa and they found a Catholic state
that corresponds with one of their
African Saints Osho see for example the
god of the forest was very similar to
John the Baptist who got a lot of his
time of the wilderness Oh sh Allah the
god of purity intelligence very some of
the Jesus Christ
interesting Yemanja the goddess of the
salt water is one that I think they had
a little sense of humor about she was
also a mother goddess and the only young
man are all does her son and he chased
her around the world and she became the
mother of all of the planets plus the
Sun and the moon and all of the other
gods and goddesses they equated her with
the Virgin Mary so here they were
imagine the slaves quarters hail Yemanja
thank you for bringing us across the
waters we're here now in a new land
please help us please protect us it
becomes the priest hail mother they
cross themselves and traits of mother
Mary and the priests say Oh what's good
Catholics they've turned out to be they
got away with us and when the slaves
were finally freed this religion the
combination of the African the Roman
Catholic and the Native American spread
all over Brazil in one form or another
among Lambada candomblé a
Baga many many smaller religions but
it's an important fortune in in Brazil
today of important religious force
especially now the groups have joined
with some of the ayahuasca groups and so
in addition to the tobacco and the
chanting and the drumming they use to
get their consciousness altered now they
can have a full-blown visionary
experience so it's interesting to see
how even in the field of religion
nothing stands still there are unions
there are collaborations in addition to
all the wars that we know of all too
well
this ongoing process of realizing that
there is so much wisdom in our 99.9% of
existence prior to modernity prior to
the Enlightenment the Industrial
Revolution it seems to be the most
common thing that we're starting to hear
about on the show over and over again
leaders in their fields are telling us
that there is so much to understand from
humans of the past and the way that they
lived and how we can embed that those
wisdoms
in today and our future to make it to
decrease suffering to increase
enlightenment and awakening around our
world that is would you say then that is
the most first principal thing we need
to be looking at it seriously is up
there among them and I think that what
happened is that Native people had to be
part of their environment they had to
have that balance to survive to have
places to live
places to sleep places to play players
so impart
in our world today and that was baby
even more important back in those days
well in order to do that you have to be
a part of nature and then when so-called
civilization came into the picture that
was a rule onto itself
and under the leadership of many of the
churches the goal was to subjugate
nature to conquer nature to use nature
not to blend with nature not to learn
from nature which was typical of the
tribal groups so again I say I don't
want to romanticize this because you
take a look at the archaeological record
there are cases of human sacrifice human
torture cases of war cases of even of
plague so this is very important
approach yeah what you just said is very
important the non the nuance of it the
not over-romanticized
only flowers but the nuance of it where
there was human sacrifice and and
quartering of I mean there were so many
weird things that were happening yeah
but but there is leave ago you described
diversion of deep interconnectedness
with nature versus conquering nature
that's very very graphic isn't it and
every once in a while you see a little
plant that's forced its way up through
the concrete and there it is waving its
banner happily that it's done a little
bit to restore the balance doesn't last
very long they can just put some more
concrete over it but at least is trying
I don't hold anything against concrete
some beautiful buildings of the made of
concrete concrete is also biodegradable
after a couple of hundred years it's
falls apart and so it's a very good
building material
it has been for quite a while but you
don't want everything concrete you know
what everything made out of cement
certainly you don't find everything
plastic yeah our ecology is a great word
the combination of ecology and
architecture yeah yeah yeah it's like
words like that are very inspirational
Stan over your years what have you
figured out is the purpose what do you
think is the purpose of creation I don't
like your oration because it infers that
there was a creator and maybe there
wasn't maybe things just evolved I think
that first of all there can't be a
universe that's empty there has to be
something there's an old saying physics
abhors a vacuum it's even more than that
if there was nothing there would still
be something filling in the nothing so
this is a stupid question as long as
there is something it doesn't stay still
this is just the way things are things
contract or things expand and our
universe right now is expanding who
knows maybe sometime in the future the
contract again but this is part of the
dance this is one of those things that
happened so I think that the purpose if
you are to call it that the purpose is
what each of us brings to this dance I
don't think there's any purpose outside
of the dance I think this is if I want
to use an analogy this is even the first
playing with itself seeing what the
possibilities are doing things that are
enjoyable doing things that are fun not
like humans not with the conscious mind
but sorted with a cosmic mentality that
we don't have the faintest idea about
the operation thereof and so for lack of
a better word we call this God fine but
then we attribute human-like
characteristics onthe God that's not
fair because then God can punish God can
scold
can can cause misfortune no that's
that's really not the best way I think
to look at this evolutionary spirit of
constant flux and constant change that's
what they're in the middle of and then
our purpose is to find meaning in this
and latched on to that part of the dance
that we enjoy the whole if we could do
well hmm
so this evolutionary force that's at
play whether you call creation or God or
all that is or source or the one or
whatever you want to call it the
universe multiverse that this that's
happening right now that we're all in
we've all endeavored into consciousness
and we're on an adventure that to find
out what our unique puzzle pieces or
what our unique instrument is or melody
that we're playing in it that is the
purpose oh yes I like your word
instrument because each of us can play
our own drummer play your own flute
dance our own dance create our own
stories this is y LM of the play in a
very that element play ourselves into
what we're doing in the universe will
have a much happier life we will take
things so seriously we won't think that
we won't have a second chance or that we
won't be liked by other people or the
hope is admired or ignored what does
that matter
in the final analysis if you're doing
something that is meaning to you
especially something that has joy and
awe and Wonder in love in it I love this
four-letter word play and I love how you
keep bringing us to it because if that
is then the purpose is this continuous
process of play of understanding itself
discovering new things and having us be
these these adventures and consciousness
we've lost in some ways this four-letter
word of play that it's become so much
about the economic machinery and about
productivity and about economics and
money and capitalism and consumption and
GDP and it's all about these metrics
that are so logical and statistically
oriented that every aspect of the heart
at play with another when we we know
deep in our core that some of the best
feelings that we ever have are when
we're at the deepest play with each
other okay when we're dancing when we're
singing when we're doing art when we're
laughing with others when we're in some
sort of a collective vibratory
environment that is ecstatic that is a
main route that we need to refocus on
well I think you're certainly right I
think that the I think that this is
something that each of us can do on our
own and we don't have absolute freedom
to do this all of us are constrained
look at the people in jail look at the
people
yeah the refugee camp look at the people
in a starving ghetto they don't have as
much freedom as maybe other people have
but still what can they do in that
limited sphere to get some joy and
happiness out of life you have to go
back to the psychiatrist Viktor Frankl
who's in the concentration camp during
the Second World War and people are
dying all around him he was a
psychiatrist and he noticed the people
who survived had found some sense of
meaning in their life either of meaning
on a very small scale or a meaning on a
very very large scale and he translated
this into existential therapy when he
got out of prison and this is one of the
major therapeutic thrusts in
in the country today now can also give
you an example from a very very
different field about the balance frank
lloyd wright who was from the state of
wisconsin so i did have a chance to meet
him when he was still alive he had the
type of architecture called organic
architecture where the buildings needed
to grow out of nature and he used
materials from the local quarries or
forests as much as he could and his
buildings are so unique so alive that
there's a sense of play about them and
the times that i met him he was full of
good humor he was a very very very
cheerful man always full of always fun
of surprises and wonder just one of many
many people who saw the possibilities of
humans and nature collaborating and
taking it to historic Heights the
restoration of balance and play in
modernity the restoration put an
emphasis on restoration because he would
restore something you're putting
something back the way it was a while
ago and let's face it we're never going
to recreate the environment that existed
in ancient times or in prehistoric times
forget that too late we have to create
our own biome to use a biological term
are owned by home that allows for humans
balance themselves of the with the rest
of nature yes remember the humans for
all of our faults we still are a part of
nature and so it's connecting with the
whole of nature rather than just our
little tiny take on nature that were
after
okay what is going on in the deepest
parts of our psyches regarding why we
are so attached to conspicuous
consumption rather than modeling the way
that trees that are larger sequester
extra carbon and then distribute them
amongst their route networks and fungal
networks to smaller trees and seedlings
why have we not modeled the same style
of distribution of excess resources
why have we went in conspicuous
consumption hoarding greed I think the
reason is that trees evolved in a
different way than humans evolved humans
evolved from swimming creatures from
crawling teeth creatures from
four-legged creatures to finally to
two-legged creatures and remember that
the purpose of evolution is twofold
evolution is looking to survive and if
something will have that help you
survive it doesn't last very long but
also to reproduce mm-hmm now to
reproduce that takes two and if you are
looking for a mate of some sort or
another and this even goes below the
animal kingdom below below the human
Kingdom into the rest of the animal
kingdom you see something that looks
good even smells good
opens up your eyes it's desirable and so
you're going to try to meet with that
and I think that this that goes not only
for men this goes for women to women
this
evolved
looking for a partner who would be
strong competent be able to care for the
children so both men and women with
shall we say many exceptions because
there are always exceptions in human
life we're both after something that was
very special and very unique trying to
drive a big car and show off trying to
have beautiful jewelry and show off
that's a hangover now that you no longer
need that if you have everything in the
world you already have your mate if you
want a mate or maybe even more than one
mate you don't need that anymore but now
you want it just for your own good it's
an evolutionary trait which is which
should have been out thrown but a lot of
these evolutionary traits keep going on
and on and on until they become so
dysfunctional that they are stopped and
died out so there's a lot of
evolutionary hangovers that are doing us
no good today
like the appendix of the human body at
once it was very important that's not so
important but it still hangs on there
and just like jealousy what was way out
of proportion both in relationships in
terms of personal goods jealousy was
once very important to protect oneself
and one's family and one's clan by
having enough possessions that they'd be
able to weather the weather
well that trait still lingers on but
down a very maladaptive dysfunctional
way so evolution has taken us a long way
and thank heavens for to them beer but
some of the evolutionary traits haven't
quite died out and are still causing us
a lot of trouble by the way human
cooperation is adapted this is something
that people are born into to cooperate
and Darwin in his book side evolution
used words like
cooperation collaboration he even used
the word love as being what keeps humans
going then somebody came up with the
term survival of the fittest he didn't
like that term no it's not that you're
fit that you survive survival of the
wisest survivalists not the most loving
a survival of the most collaborative
this is what keeps things going and a
lot of that has been lost but it's in
any Darwin book and many scholars have
emphasized the importance of
collaboration above and beyond the
aggression again that served the purpose
you had to fight to protect your family
to protect your lives when there were
enemies so that had to be there too but
you don't fight as often as you
collaborate in fact there's a lot of
evidence that even today with all of its
Wars and all of its bloodshed is much
more peaceful by and large than the
world was a hundred years ago and we
also know this on the human scale that
is bullying is bad a sexual assault is
it's much less than it was 50 years ago
so drama highlights all of the
misfortunes in the world but you take a
broad point of view and you say as far
as human behavior goes things are
getting a little bit better but will
they get better in time for people to
raise their consciousness and realize
something drastic has to be done to
achieve balance with nature that's the
critical question of our time and the
fact that global warming is still not
accepted by many important segments of
society the fact that fuel-efficient
machines are not accepted by a great
proportion of a society there are still
power blocks and very important power
blocks that for their own purposes are
keeping a lot of these collaborative
removing ahead as quickly as they might
there are power blocks in the ways of
the elevation of consciousness we need
to both remove those power blocks as
well as find ways to amplify the
elevation of consciousness as as quickly
as possible towards those feelings of
interconnectedness harmony peace
prosperity like your choosing of
evolutionary hangovers I like your words
there these are very interesting why has
it been that we've continued on this
path of greed and conspicuous
consumption when these things could have
been already evolved out why is it that
they are still here and then what other
ones are these hangovers and I like how
you also gave the difference between
humans evolving from the oceans until
today versus trees just having different
aspects of evolutionary trajectory over
time to be able to biomimic though I
think is one of the waste to maximize
prosperity oh well aggression fighting
of course that's going to survive
because it's adaptive a lot of people
who fight to kill them who are mean and
nasty or who amass great fortunes
because they're cruel and selfish
they're going to survive simply because
they have the power to survive and so
it's going to be a while before other
traits become more powerful cooperation
love unselfishness forgiveness caring
yes and so those show that this is a
better way to live this will carry the
day yes and it's been said just also by
the dial AMA and other very evolved
spiritual leaders that it has been
because of cooperation and collaboration
operation that we've been able to get
this far and that we need to remember
that in the evolutionary trajectory and
prioritize that in unconditional love
and depressants and interconnectedness
and carry these things forward as our
best selves as we figure out what is my
unique instrument that I want to play
well what's my unique dance that I want
to play yeah that collectively that
having a social fabric that's very
conducive to people like figuring out
what their instrument or what their
dance is is going to be paramount
absolutely yeah okay Sam we have to talk
about your time you were a former
director of the Kent State University
Child Study Center what was going on
during that time of doing of course
we'll get you some we'll get you some
thanks everyone for tuning in
greatly appreciate you can let us know
your thoughts in the comments as we go
or in the live chat okay so let's let's
jump thinking organ let's jump to the
time at the doing child's study at the
Child Study Center I can't State
University well this was back in the
early 1960s and I was director of the
Child Study Center at Kent State
University in Ohio and we trained
teachers to do diagnostic work with
children with learning difficulties of
one sort or another and we also had a
summer program so they could improve
their reading and academic skills for
children of all ages but even back in
those days I took a somewhat different
point of view than many of my colleagues
because I thought that a lot of these
problems were neurologically based
and I think that this has been borne out
of course there are familial
contributions educational contributions
intelligence contributions that keep a
child from reading efficiently but I
think that the key is how the brain is
connected and once you know how the
brain is operating you can modify your
teaching techniques to adjust to this
type of mentality not that one is better
than the other they're just different
from each other children of what we call
dyslexia have short attention spans
now instead of giving them drugs which
is the usual medical response to this do
something that is fast-moving put them
on a computer game do something that'll
increased and enhance their attention
this is attention deficit yes
yeah attention don't especially okay
attention deficit disorder okay yes and
the met the neurological term underlying
this is dyslexia which means problem
reading but I like the new term better
the attention deficit disorder first of
all because it doesn't put it within the
psychiatric framework of being a
disorder and it's just what it says it
focuses on attention the attention is
not there not there most of the time
many of the some of the children with
attention deficit disorder can sing five
stanzas of the latest popular song or
can do rapping for half an hour now
that's that attention deficit disorder
is not only with the child but with the
environment the environment hasn't found
ways to engage the child and who enhance
the attention this takes us back to that
instrument that the child has already
began identifying what their instrument
is but the environment of the act
setting is not conducive for them to
amplify their interest in that
instrument yes exactly
now back in those days I have many
poignant memories one mother brought her
child and he was diagnosed as autistic
now that was back in the days when the
autistic mother was called the empty
fortress that she didn't have enough
love to give the child and so there's
nothing inside and so the child couldn't
develop socially as well as one would
think
and I said no it's not your fault your
son's brain is just wired differently
than that of other children now that
just gave her such relief and again back
in those days mothers are being blamed
for just about everything and with a
couple of sections though it wasn't
exceptions no it wasn't their fault at
all it was the poverty it was the poor
schools it was the it was the
differences in the brain it was the
social group they were with yes and so
the overview is just not broad enough to
do justice to some of these kids who are
having such trouble and having and
having difficulties in school and I
actually wrote several research papers
on that topic we also had a few very
very bright children who came to us for
diagnosis who had IQs up to the nine now
into the 160s 170s
and then we see Justin home pastimes
that the parents could do to occupy
their time and to give them something
extra that they wouldn't get in school
so we know for the large number of
children yeah but yeah yet benefited me
because I could see the great the great
variety of children with special needs
and how no one-size-fits-all of
how different treatments are needed for
sure there was different different
issues yeah I appreciate how deep that
your study is on the multi variability
of it that we like talking about this in
terms of a seed that as being de said
the disadvantages into this body that's
being happed that's happening is that if
the seed doesn't have the right
nutrients if it doesn't have the love
the water the food the shelter the
education electricity it doesn't have
the social fabric that's fostering them
to identify their instrument and bring
it out into the world that that seed is
not going to have as many it's not going
to flower and produce as many fruits for
its family for itself for its for the
world at large so basically the
nutrients need to be there in the unique
personalized style of identifying that
instrument and then bringing that forth
into the world needs to be there
let's also touch on the time as former
director of how do I say this my money
my money my Amana teas the my Amana teas
Medical Center in the dream research
laboratory and that was in Brooklyn New
York and you were doing dream telepathy
experiments with Montague Ullman yes yes
teach us about dream telepathy
experiments dream research we spend a
third of our lives asleep yes so what is
going on well again that's a product of
evolution sleep is very adaptive dreams
are very adaptive if we didn't have
sleep we wouldn't have a chance to rest
and restore yes we wouldn't have a
chance to use the word again balanced
equilibrium sleep helps us to gain
equilibrium and so do dreams dreams help
us to work out issues emotional issues
that were unresolved during the day and
we find those in dreams dreams help us
to remember things which are important
and discard things that aren't important
dreams help us to problem solve they
help us to plan for the future they are
if they couldn't do any of those things
they wouldn't have survived the dreams
are adaptive and so they're built into
the human brain and if you tamper with
dreams by keeping a person awake five
nights in row you suffer the
consequences they're not going to be
very very alert because they have this
whole log jam of memories and feelings
and emotions to work through the system
and so that you can be bright and fresh
the next day now what we introduced
which was novel was to see if somebody
could influence another person's dreams
and a distance so he had a person at one
end of our Hospital who was given the
sealed envelope and people to the other
a person at the other end of the
hospital with electrodes on her head
watching the EEG and the rapid eye
movements which indicate dreaming and
once the so-called sender got to her
room she would wait half an hour because
you don't have any dreams in the first
half hour of the night there's some
exceptions and then we start to open the
envelope and look at the picture they
were always very colourful pictures
filled with what we might call
archetypes and vivid vivid emotional
images and then at the other end of the
hospital we would be watching the
electroencephalograph and then the eyes
walked back and forth we knew the person
was dreaming so very gently we woke up
the person said what's been going
through your mind
and then they would speak the dream into
the microphone mm-hmm and over the 10 .
10-year period of time that I was there
we collected hundreds of Dreams and we
did an analysis of every single one of
them every single night say that we had
somebody with us for eight nights well
we had a collection of eight sets of
dreams then we call it a team of judges
saying now match the picture with these
dreams and of course they didn't know
the match
but leave it or not they made the match
more successfully than chance especially
where they looked at one picture and
said that picture has to go with this
set of dreams it's a group of Mexicans
carrying guns and they're marching over
the mountains and there's some women
following after them and that's can only
pertain to those dreams that this
participant had this dream about warfare
men and women both fighting we're
mountain in the background clouds in the
sky and it was because someone else at
the other side of the hospital was
opening and looking yes that person was
the only one in the world who knew what
the picture was because it had been
taken from a large number of sealed
envelopes now the person who was
receiving from the sender we're simply
going about doing their dreams and
getting their dreams recorded so then
this speaks to the collective
intelligence that we're all a part of I
think how active consciousness would be
a collective consciousness or sometimes
there wasn't much intelligence needed to
produce the picture sometimes the
picture was nonverbal or had their lolly
be motion in it but some aspect of
consciousness was there now after 50
years of dreams have up with the
experiments all over the world all of
the results have been tallied and the
chances of these connections being made
by chance is like one out of several
thousand the odds are just incredible
you go to Wikipedia which you should
never do if you want to find anything
out about my research because they just
like parasite
they will have statements that are not
true they will say that the person
looked at the picture before they went
to the distant room that's not true and
they will say that there was no
replication in our experiments and that
is not true so Wikipedia is good for
many many things but it's not good for
my biography or anybody who has been
engaging in a type of parapsychology
Wikipedia thinks ooh the Sun sinks it
sinks parapsychology is a pseudoscience
I think they're wrong but you know I
don't have the money to prosecute or
start a lawsuit and I've written to them
several times they do not make the
change other friends with minors written
they don't make the changes even the
what they're pretty is absolutely false
this is one of also the biggest
challenges of our time is to be able to
bring together spirituality with science
in a more harmonious way because
parapsychology has many aspects to it
that are very deeply rooted in spiritual
experience and it's sometimes difficult
for science to begin trying to quantify
that yes yeah I'm glad you use the word
spiritual instead of religious because
religion can be very divisive can take
people apart keep people from
collaborating but spirituality
transcends all of that and spirituality
is very much akin to the Union we've
been talking about for the past several
minutes yes yes yes okay I hope we can
do more experiments on both people
having that union but also on what's
going on in the collective consciousness
especially in that third of time that
were laboratories doing outstanding work
and there are a few a few people that
supported the be all foundation of
Portugal is the largest foundation to
support parapsychological research by
the way and they also support research
and ordinary
psychology and so they're trying to
bring those two fields together which is
very commendable they have wonderful
conferences once every two years and
then they have a book of proceedings and
so that's a very good charitable use
that is trying to do what you're talking
about and I think that excellent there
is no sense of saying that spirituality
and science cannot coexist because you
need some guidelines to use science in a
way that there's life enhancing yes I
mean science can treat a mega bomb but
how can science tell you not to use that
mega bomb well that's the role of
spirituality that establishes spirit
establish morality and ethics and
compassion and empathy okay let's now
talk about hypnosis so you were the past
president of the Society for
psychological hypnosis which awarded you
its 2002 Award for distinguished
contributions to professional hypnosis
what were you doing during that time
well I've been involved in hypnosis for
a long time ever since I've been with
high school and then I started to study
it seriously and I'm not a clinician
another psychotherapist and so I don't
use it for those purposes except once in
a while I will help a friend stop
smoking by hypnosis and well I actually
have been pretty successful along those
lines I have a charge that I mean it's
just sort of service to their to their
good health but hypnosis really I think
should be used much more often
depression is a very serious problem in
our country the pressure often leads to
suicide it leads to poor human relations
as leads to work stoppage and typically
Prozac or some other drug is given for
depression
and um
fortunate works for a while and then it
has side effects and some of the side
effects can be pretty gruesome now a
very large study was done with hypnosis
hypnotizing people who were depressed
and having people take antidepressants
and taking people from the same walk of
life same gender same age and the people
in hypnosis did actually a little better
than the people who are on medication
and what was the procedure for the
hypnosis the procedure for hypnosis
let me just spelled this out yes because
there are many many procedures but I
have to tell you somebody I get their
consents and then I ask if they will
mind closing their eyes and if they
don't mind closing their eyes I have
them hold out an arm and I tell them
that the arm is getting heavier and
heavier and heavier and heavier and by
the time it hits their lap they'll be
open to suggestion and of course we know
that the suggestion will be because I've
gotten permission to even them that
suggestion yes how they will begin to
lose interest in tobacco already tobacco
product and I have another at number of
exercise as I go through and sometimes I
can help somebody in just one weekend
and after three days of work no more
tobacco and certainly no more
antidepressants if they were depressed
but I because I say I've been using it
for tobacco cessation myself but the
people that use it for depression use a
variety of ways there are many many ways
to hypnotize people sometimes people
have their eyes open sometimes people
are moving but what's important is the
intent what are the people trying to do
with the hypnosis how are they trying to
self regulate themselves so that they
will not smoke they will not be
depressed and this will all come
naturally because the hypnotist is
actually pulling upon the resources of
the person being hypnotized
personally I think all hypnosis is
basically self-hypnosis the person who
wants to be hypnotized knows what needs
to be done
get some Ally repeat the night words
write words but the person is ruining
the work him or herself it's bringing an
ally in for the process of awakening
away from depression or away from to
addiction so that's so interesting so
it's actually a self-hypnosis process
bringing in an ally
okaying them to be an ally in the
assisting process yes and of course if
gnosis can be used with a variety of
psychotherapy it works very well with
what we call cognitive behavior therapy
psychodynamic therapy humanistic
psychotherapy existential psychotherapy
I know people that used hypnosis of each
one of those interventions maybe
hypnosis can be used for awakening to
feelings of interconnectedness and unity
with each other and with nature well
actually this has been tried and it's
been successful the question is how can
you make that long-lasting yeah you have
to build something into the into the
system to make a floral and a
long-lasting now the people who are in
psychedelic psychotherapy like
psilocybin for depression they are also
achieving very high rates of depressed
of success and the depression does tend
to modify and stay away even Eskew is -
psilocybin sessions and so if you when
you're doing a psychotherapy of course
you're looking for something
long-lasting I have seen what we call
faith healing sessions and somebody is
walking in a walker and the Evangelist
says
you're healed puts his hands on the
person they dropped the Walker walk away
dancing and singing everybody is happy
the next day they're back looking for
their Walker again
this type of very dramatic intervention
shows what the human mind and body are
capable of but it can't be done in one
flash drive one very dramatic instance
it has to be done over a period of time
to make sure that the self-control sets
in and that the gains are not lost that
the gains are kept solid yes yes which
in many ways speaks to the the cycle
that we that many people are taking with
their awakening where it's just going
for one awakening to the next to the
next and the next
rather than taking the time to also have
a deep contemplative integration period
that then kind of ossify the awakening
the previous milestones of the awakening
in yes this is so important
Freud used this in psychoanalysis there
has to be a working through as part of
psychoanalysis to make sure the person
doesn't fall back of the bad habits and
people who are doing psychedelic drug
sessions who are therapists also talked
about a period of time where the person
has to maintain their gains so that they
don't lose what they've gained and
sometimes they come back and do not take
the psychedelic but they just talk about
what they have gained what they have
learned on how they can retain this and
any of these any of the psycho therapies
or self-help programs we're talking
about the question I have is ok what's
happened two years from now if something
is still helping 2 years from now then I
think it's worthy of attention I have
two years as the minimum
we you've been speaking about this as
we've been talking you're a fellow at
Society for the scientific study
religion
fellow Society for the scientific study
of sexuality we've been talking about
this a little bit throughout what have
been the main realizations for you with
those realizations first of all people
are very very different that comes as no
surprise but when it comes to religion
when it comes to therapy
when it comes to behavior change one
size does not fit all it's a wonder that
people can get something out of the diet
when there are so many types of diets
well one diet does not fit all one
person will maintain a new weight
indefinitely of other personal bounce
right back after one or two months same
thing with with addictions this is what
I say
the people who I know that I've helped
stop smoking twelve two years later they
all stopped smoking and to this day as
far as I know they're not smoking
anymore so I think that the one thing
you have to view is the difference in
people but then there's another
important thing that I've earned and
that is that people are fairly fragile
if people weren't fragile they wouldn't
come down with post-traumatic stress
disorder but a person has a trauma
they're in war they're in combat
something horrible happens yes most
people bounce back but 15 to 20 percent
don't smoke bounce back and they're in
misery for the rest of their lives
unless they get therapy and also people
are fragile in the sense of their
feelings are easily hurt their egos are
eagerly bruised
they give up too easily and it's this
fragility that needs to be strengthened
and this needs to be done only on child
rearing in an education but I think this
is where spiritual discipline comes in
yeah
a person can pray can meditate can you
Taichi or the martial arts can engage in
contemplation a number of regular
exercises can really anchor a person and
keep a person resilient and help a
person bounce back when there are
troubled experiences yeah I think that
the other to answer your question other
thing that I've learned is that people
respond very well to love and people who
are incapable of loving very deeply can
at least be kind I think that kindness
can be just as helpful as love for many
many people and again some people for
one reason or another are afraid to love
they're afraid of losing their autonomy
they're afraid of boundaries well at
least they could accept kindness and
don't put down kindness because I think
it's a something that's a very admirable
human trait than something we should be
developing much more of so those are
some of the things that I have learned
in these pastimes and activities we've
been talking about when you were leading
division 32 Society for humanistic
psychology of the APA
what were your takeaways as well well
the American Psychological Association
has about 50 divisions and I've been
pressed
the two of them the Society for
humanistic psychology and the Society
for psychological hypnosis and the term
is only one year so you can't do too
much in one year that's what I tried to
do was to bring in speakers and programs
that ordinarily would not be thought of
in a psychological setting I brought in
Richard de Mille for example who has
written several books about Carlos
Castaneda showing how some of Casta
natives claims simply could not be true
given the places he described in Mexico
describing the drugs he described in
medicine Mexico and the tribes he
described and I think that this was a
wonderful example of taking something
vej Andheri in the culture and just
double checking it to see if it holds up
now on the positive side Richard the
mill said a lot of the advice that Casa
de de gives is very worthwhile and I
think there's a lot that can be learned
from him by focusing on the teachings of
Don Juan and just take with a grain of
salt some of the stories of both jumping
off a cliff death by the been either a
fantasy or might have been a person with
a vivid imagination or a person on drugs
but focus on the teachings and the
meaning and what you can learn from us
which I thought was very good advice
yeah and also I brought in Eve Sizemore
who was the original Eve from the book
the three faces of Eve and what people
don't realize is that when the movie was
showing which one Joanne Woodward
Academy Award that the real Eve whose
name was Chris was in the motel about to
commit suicide because a fourth pace had
developed and she thought she had been a
great failure to a psychiatrist
her psychiatrists Nathalie a fourth a
fifth and the sixth yeah it was her she
kept going to therapy she finally found
a very sensible therapist who I think
knew much more how to handle a case of
dissociative identity disorder than the
other ones did but she also had
spiritual help and she helped from her
children whenever a new face came the
children of namath there was one face
that they called the polkadot kid
because this personality were nothing
but polka-dots another one called the
chocolate kid because she do nothing
with eat chocolates and at the end there
were 21 faces and they all merged into
one face thanks to a very skilled
psychotherapist and then Eve had a dream
Chris had a dream that all of her
identities were walking across a stage
and they're all bowing and saying
goodbye and after she woke up from that
dream she never had other personalities
again so it's it's special events like
this that I brought to the Society of
humanistic psychology also we did a lot
in terms of continuing education we
collaborated with other divisions we
brought a lot of women for leadership
roles brought in people of color
whenever we could they have a very
diverse but very very strong Society and
remember that humanistic psychology can
be very easily defined psychology as a
whole we defined as the discipline study
behavior and experience
well humanistic psychology is one's
first step further
behavior he has experience yes intention
yes meaning yes humanistic psychology
focuses on what people intend to do the
meaning they give out of the experience
and so in that sense this goes deeper
than most other
roaches to South psychology thank you
this led you to win the APA Award for
distinguished contributions to the
International advancement of psychology
all of the last what is it a thousand we
said so many a thousand either authoring
co-authoring or editing a thousand books
monographs articles on such a
wide-ranging amount of subjects I want
to bring up some of them now we have we
have several that you've brought with us
we have your we have your most we have
all the way up to your most recent here
which is a integrated care for the
traumatized a whole person approach how
to take care of people who have
post-traumatic stress disorder in other
forms of trauma this is very common in
our times and that's leading to
dysfunction leading to suicide leading
to very severe mental illness but these
stories in this particular book are
collected from different parts of the
world and that shows how different
communities have helped people who are
traumatized and how they can use
psychodrama
how they can use psychotherapy how they
can use service even an animal can be a
therapist to some traumatized people yes
and so this sort of gives people sort of
a variety of new ways of working with
traumatized people instead of just
giving them medication and forgetting
about them yes yes I love the focus on a
whole person approach which takes in
spirituality psychology medicine social
work psychiatry I mean here just looking
through a couple of there is you're
already beginning to talk about creating
safe spaces
for the process of healing also you're
giving examples of when the devastating
7.0 earthquake hit Haiti so how on a
planetary level that there are
geological shifts that happen that cause
serious amounts of trauma absolutely
yeah it's very wide-ranging
and this is a very trauma can be created
in wide-ranging amount of ways and then
there's a multidisciplinary way for us
to approach the process of yes sure
remember that I said I become aware of
how sensitive how fragile people are
this is why people get so easily
traumatized because experiences like
this or not within their everyday
experience and especially acts of
cruelty people are for the most part are
not basically crew people are basically
kind and when they are in the middle of
war or if they were bullied or if they
are harassed if they are raped these are
deliberate acts of cruelty from other
people now sometimes the trauma comes
from a flood or Susa meter an earthquake
well that's nature that simply is not
nature punishing us this is just nature
reminding us that we are a part of
nature and you can't boss nature around
a nature will do its own thing whether
we like it or not I also noticed them
you have in here you talk about
indigenous psychotherapy you talk about
the limitations of evidence-based
research which is very interesting
yeah yes there's a chapter in there that
use some shamanic techniques for for
working with young people and we thought
was very important to get the shamans in
the book one way or the other
yes mm-hmm yes yes and then the
limitations is very interesting we were
talking about bringing together science
and spirituality there are going to be
interesting ways that it will be a big
challenge to try and take something like
subjective first-person experience and
try and create some sort of a biometric
state that um that correlates with that
yes yeah yeah yeah that's not impossible
I think that might be a future goal I'm
excited for then and this actually part
for here you do actually talk about the
future of integrative care for the
traumatized teachers about that mm-hmm
well it's mainly some of the things
we've been talking about today in terms
of using nature more putting traumatized
people out in nature having them do some
work with animals having them do in
selected cases work with plant medicine
like the ayahuasca and the mushrooms you
were talking about earlier today about
finding ways that they can become more
resilient and can bounce back and can be
getting stronger and so the trauma can
actually be the Gateway to a positive
personality change and a person can come
up through its stronger than they were
at the beginning that's another very
very common theme with the guests that
we have on the show that on the other
side of the deepest traumas are actually
the most brilliant treasures and that it
takes a very modality of healing that is
in all these different ones that you
listed that enables them to go through
the process of discovering that then so
that's most recent and then we have next
most recent this one that was 2019 this
is 2012 the shamanic powers of Rolling
Thunder what is this one about well I
think many of your listeners would like
to read both of my books about Rolling
Thunder I wrote them with city and the
Morningstar the grants and the Rolling
Thunder and these are collection of
stories about this remarkable medicine
man and how he actually is that holy was
a social activist but he healed people
and also it gives his principles for
right living he is just a Paragon
wouldn't I
about today in terms of people being
close to nature mm-hmm
and how when he established a healing
center called meadow Tati that he had
brought with some friends help there
wasn't any water and so he took a dozing
stick and walked up and down the land
until the step went down and when the
sick went down he had his Braves his
assistants go and dig and after three
weeks three feet nothing one more four
feet down they had water they had spring
water yeah then he went to the other end
of the property a few days later said
this one needs to have some water too so
he took his dowsing stick and that was
sick went down and they dug water there
now I was not there to see the operation
but I was there to see the wells and
those are genuine wells there's no doubt
about that
but when I was with rolling thunders one
night he took me off to her his property
ends and the wood begins and he started
to howl mm-hmm and yeah I was used to
anything from Rolling Thunder so I
didn't think much of the howling but
then some coyote came right out of the
forest and they were so close I could
have reached down and touched them but I
just stayed my distance there was very
respectful for them and the head of the
pack was howling back and forth to
Rolling Thunder Wow having a
conversation well I said ruling Thunder
what is it all about after they left
back into the woods he said well we have
a contract a lot of farmers kill coyotes
because the Coyotes read the chicken
hoop but our agreement is we will not
kill the coyote if you don't kill our
chickens
yeah and for all the years we've been
here we have applause a single chicken
techhire so the Seas communicating
partly he's communicating with the
Coyotes yes speaking their language
their unique type of
occasion where there's language whether
it's telepathy who knows what the type
of thing that happens when you remain
close to nature when you remain close to
nature profound things like and this
also reminds me a little bit of Bryant
Austin who go who goes out into the
middle of the seas and whereas many
people just try and come for a couple
hours to take pictures of whales he
would go out for weeks and weeks at a
time and slowly but surely show his
vulnerability and that he is trying to
be friendly to the whales and all of a
sudden the whales would come and swim so
close to him and he would take these
gorgeous full-length photos of it and of
their eyes and their whole entire bodies
and so when we stay close to other
humans when we stay close to the plants
when we look at a tree for more than
just its little like tree icon we can
actually see the deep interconnectedness
of the insects and the birds and the
animals that are in the tree the way
that the light engages with the tree and
so we see more when we when we stay with
a dog or a cat or you know wolves in
skates or just other animals for a
longer period of time we can see more
and we can experience more and maybe it
may seem strange at first to try and do
something along the lines of communicate
in some way whether it's self ethically
or through language but it sure does
energetically we can even see it with
our dogs and cats energetically that
they're like you were saying with
therapy with the animals or we have a
very interconnected relationship with
even the ones we've demented people when
they communicate don't think you're
gonna do it by talking because it's a
tone of voice the animal pick up on not
the words and sometimes just playing
with them being with them I'm not saying
anything is a good way to get to know
them yes yes I love that in here mother
earth is our great mentor
I love also I want to know you you said
that Rolling Thunder actually has the
ways of good life of the right life what
was the keys of that right life what the
key points of that right life the key
points is just what we've been talking
about he would say the key points are
having a balance in your life having a
balance with nature
and also having fun this is where play
comes in the young Rolling Thunder put a
very great stress upon having fun he
will have a lot of games on his
spiritual community a lot of things that
people enjoy doing and he said that back
in the old days people played more than
they did work and he's right but if you
look at tribal people there is very
little work that has to be done in most
places and a lot of time to make love to
play games
to explore to do our Kirke etc making me
feel very emotional because that is the
world that we want that's the next world
that we want but remember this doesn't
happen in all tribes that's why I say
don't over by mathur sighs yes yes
there's some tribe area is very very
deadly and have very very unfair rules
especially to women Native Americans
before the European invasion probably
had the best societies for women of any
other place in the world why with very
few exceptions women held an equivalent
amount of the power with men women could
make important decisions women always
often were in charge of the finances in
charge of training there were women's
councils with made decisions that they
override the men's councils you just
read each tribe of course did things a
little differently but there was a great
deal of power
two women and one of the reasons that
neither Americans are such a bad shape
today with a higher suicide rate of any
ethnic group in the United States is
that the old ways have been disregarded
and women have lost their power Western
religions the commune that the mean
women the don't get men and women enough
power and that users like sin and guilt
and hell and damnation
that were very very foreign to the
Native American Way of thinking wanted
to talk some more about Rolling Thunder
and I'll just tell one other story yes
please uh he was helping poor people in
his community gather pine nuts from
trees and that was a good source of
protein for them and then some tractors
came in and started to cut down the
trees sell the wood and turn the jurors
into cropland Easter was against the law
but they didn't care they either bought
off the police or the police didn't know
they were doing that and a lot of
rolling thunders people said let's get
out with our rifles and kill them off
and the Rolling Thunder said no less to
find a peaceful solution and so they did
two things one night they went out and
they videotaped the tractors and so that
there was proof that they were doing
that and then they poured sand into the
engines of the tractors the next days
the tractors couldn't move and some of
rolling thunders people on a airplane to
washington d.c
to appeal to the Department of Interior
which of course saw that this was
against the law and that sent the agents
out to keep the trees from being plowed
down again so Rolling Thunder was a very
skilled
tactician in the addition to being a
very skilled healer and then we talked a
little bit about one of the 2010 books
haunted by combat understanding PTSD and
war veterans and the different
modalities for healing as well talked
about that a little bit and then we've
been talking a bit about the varieties
of anomalous experience as well and
examining the scientific evidence well
that's my best-selling book yes that's a
psychological book I did it with three
co-authors yet so card Dania and what we
did was to devote chapters to such
unusual experiences as out-of-body
experiences past life experiences lucid
dreaming anomalous healing experiences
synesthesia where you can smell color
and taste sound and we devote a chapter
each one of these experiences because
these are extraordinary experiences and
then we pointed out what part what
science has to say about them in some
cases science can pretty well explain
what happens in some cases sciences not
really reached that point yet to do a
complete explanation and so a lot of
psychologists and other people too have
bought that book now in the second
edition because it sort of clears things
up for them especially the people who
have another body experience and think
they're going crazy yeah no they're not
going crazy this is one of those
experiences as many people have it seems
to me then that when you write varieties
of anomalous experience and hopefully
other people from around the world
take a look that then it's trying to
showcase how these deeply profound a
variety of anomalous experiences many
times spirits
can actually be somewhat seen through
different scientific lenses yes that's
true and again we have a whole chapter
on spiritual experiences that's the last
chapter in the book right and so many
people have had these near-death
experiences or have had deep feelings of
ego loss or ego death or deep feelings
of interconnectedness with all things or
or synesthesia like you were describing
there's and there's ways to see it these
things neurologically as well where
things like the default mode Network get
turned off and new profound ways of
seeing the world interconnections
between brain regions light up yeah yeah
things like that and I think that's
starting to become more and more
mainstream and popular which is great
because then this excessive rumination
that it feels like we have so much can
in a sense be we can transcend that and
yeah yes hope yeah let's hope yes yes so
that was um that was one of the
bestsellers and then extraordinary
dreams on how to work with them we've
been talking a little bit about that and
dream telepathy and then this here which
was one of your earlier writings this
was 1988 yes okay personal mythology the
psychology of your evolving self using
ritual dreams and imagination to
discover your inner story teach us about
how myth takes play in psychology and
parapsychology well that book also goes
under the name the mythic path yes the
second edition went under the name of
the mythic task the third edition is
back to personal mythology is still
still in trance still easy to get what
is it's it's 22 activities it's a self
health book people can take a look at
the activities and they can do whichever
ones they want but we try to build the
activity so that once people finish the
activity they're not the same and the
activities are things that they can do
in their imagination they
that they could do with friends or
neighbors things they can do with
strangers but it's designed to help them
find their own personal mythology what
they believe in what they don't believe
in what their positive traits are what
their negative traits are and we call
the myth because a myth is a story but
it's a special type of story it's a
story about the most important things in
life and it's more than that it affects
your behavior if you really believe in a
myth strong enough it's going to affect
your behavior like if you believe in the
myth I can never do anything as well as
my sister you will grow up and until you
die you will be thinking I can never do
anything as well as my sister and you'll
never reach your full capacity versus
the opposite feeling which is I love
what my sister has done and I am going
to also strive and become even better
that's the positive personal myth and
that's what the book tries to help
people to do change their negative
personal myths and who positive personal
illness and they can do that through
their imagination like you just did or
through dreams or by discussion by
writing short stories doing paintings
doing dance number of ways that people
can get to those very very deep belief
systems some you are to keep others you
are the change beautiful so then we at
22 total yes I'm a waste - in a sense
take us from negative myth to positive
myth yes and from negative behavior to
positive behavior for us to really fully
realize that unique instrument that we
have and to bring it forth into the
world mm-hmm
yeah I love that okay personal mythology
is a powerful antidote for modern lives
caught in the grip of a disorienting
world
and I love how there's those experiences
that your listing in here it's so
wide-ranging even something even
something as simple as passing a couple
minutes before you go to bed on just
writing writing or propagating you know
just getting yourself ready for your
dream state with positive uh or art or
all these different other sorts of ways
and then feeling what works really well
for you sharing that what they can
experience with other people okay and so
many of the books though the link is in
the bio below to all of the different
books to the Amazon profile of stanley's
check that out and as you do check that
out make sure that you're sharing what
you're learning with other people and
having conversations with other people
about these profound subjects okay I do
want to ask you in terms of our
trajectory it seems as though we're here
in in Silicon Valley where everyone is
talking about artificial intelligence
everyone's talking about biotechnology
and genetic engineering about neuro
technology neural prosthetics neural
laces we're talking about augmented
reality and virtual reality worlds
quantum computing where are all of these
things taking us is our is our is
humanity a biological bootloader for a
digital super intelligence well I think
you've all the important developments
that are going on here and more so in
Silicon Valley than anywhere else
probably and I think that this is a good
example of where the science has gotten
ahead of the spirituality that's right
because you can use all of everything
that you've mentioned you can use in
positive ways but you can always use it
the negative ways you can use it in
positive ways to diagnose disease and to
find better treatments for disease you
can also use it to augment Strela
learning in children children like the
ones I dealt with many decades
go who can't read very well can't think
very quickly and you can use a number of
these apps a number of these computer
games to help sharpen them up and so
that they better doing better in school
do better in life I think that many of
the things that you've mentioned are
more social they're helping us predict
where society is going and this is
important because what jobs are going to
be available what jobs are going to be
outdated so people know well enough what
jobs to train for and what jobs to study
for if that job Peters out and they have
to find another way of living it's a
shame to think of the people who went to
college several decades ago specializing
in one particular thing and now a robot
is taken over or there's a better way to
do it or it's passe nobody's interested
than that so people really need
something to fall back upon many people
think that they're set for the rest of
their life and then they lose their job
because the new technology has come in
and they have to go back and start over
again
no don't take anything for granted don't
make any assumptions
some people think though everything is
all set and there's a flood like you're
having now on the East Coast in the
United States ruins everything they have
to start all over again and part of
resilience is to look ahead part of
Dreams is to look ahead we cannot
predict the future 100% of the time but
we must have something to fall back upon
both in terms of our skills and in terms
of our moral fiber our way of deciding
what is right rather is wrong what
people are going to help us and what
people are we going to help what is the
quarter the core basics of our identity
that will be there whether in a
concentration camp whether were
in the mountains whether we are in jail
whether we are crippling with illness
but what can we hang on to that will
pull us through in the long run and it
may be that that is those feelings of
unity those feelings of
interconnectedness yes the more
interconnectedness we have the more we
can fold back upon so this brings us
full circle the more interconnections we
have not only with people but with other
forces of nature and whatever is divine
in our worldview or spiritual in our
worldview the more resilience we will be
and the better we'll be able to cope
with whatever comes our way what do you
think is most beautiful most beautiful I
would say and using the broad term I
would see love as being the most
beautiful thing love for a family love
for a girlfriend or a boyfriend love for
nature love for Humanity love for a
project but in love we go out of
ourselves and make connection with
somebody or something else and so I
think that love can lead to the
connection that we're talking about and
I think that whenever I see these acts
of love this is very inspirational to me
it's very beautiful and of course it
could be turned into a poem or a
painting or a story which would be a
work of art but even without that it is
aesthetic in that awakens our sense of
beauty and right this harmony connected
us and oneness
so beautiful thank you you are more than
welcome Stan thank you so much for
coming on earth my best to all of your
viewers and listeners we're so grateful
that you joined us thank you thank you
for our great work over the years I
strongly believe that this is butterfly
affected into people's hearts and will
continue doing so so thank you thanks
thank you thank you you're as well thank
you thank you whoo thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about the
subjects that Stan was teaching us on
the show today check out the links in
the bio below to Stan Lee crib nerd
weebly.com also his parasite work
profile page and his book profile page
on Amazon where you can find all of the
great books that we talked about today
and more on the incredible topics that
were talked about on the program so
check that out and support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe in
support them support the organization's
and your communities and around the
world support them help them grow you
can find our links in the bio below
dissimulation so we can do continue
doing cool things like bringing great
guests likes and onto the program you
find our Pay Pal patreon cryptocurrency
links on the Bible oh you can design
cool merch and get paid and thank you
again for tuning in we wish you the
absolute best on your journeys towards
awakening towards enlightenment and
towards building that next world we love
you very much thanks for tuning in we'll
see you soon peace